Hello Korea Agilent Technologies Science and Technology Symposium Day 2 First
Session Welcome to That Eye Comics and Climb Up That LifeCare 1st Generation Development In
fact, we will start by giving you a brief notice from the starting point
.  Jirim and Deokseong will be there for 10 minutes after the
presentation Feel free at any time Ah Gae Hwagi Choi Yeonhee Chang uh If you leave a question, I will
answer it.
Like before retirement
Yes, today is the second 3. How are you going? The first Cecil on the second day is
scheduled to be held.
He is
also a Director of the Asia-Pacific Glycoanalysis Research and Education Center, which works with government agencies and local industries to develop and validate new analytical platforms for the analysis of sugar and phase proteins
.
He received his Ph.D. from
Davis and worked as an est specialist for UC Davis for the past 8 years
.
The prayers of the co-founder of Clico Matrix 2, an ovarian cancer diagnostics company, as
well as the mass spec to set review site dport
bional cs and the boron tech science and technology and the good house advisors by phone
rest
.  I will proceed with Professor Ahn's session from
now.
I'm very happy today I'm
talking about the kid comics and the know proteomics and how much
progress has been made scientific technological progress Then we'll move forward again
Comics Uncle Suffering Pro Duo Mix 2 Minutes Als Got the remaining engagement
I would like to take a look at what they are and have time to share them.
Uh, this is a very famous painting.
I've seen 5 mix techs we know well below. This is the
presentation of the schematic of the g. From the messy mix, then now, the DNA-
related will nomics. Just because of the below, the transcriptor mix.
Now, when we talk about that child's knife,
we will say that it is the most representative thing during the pk time, which is the consciousness with the 4-po stress of Ooty.
It's
Ike, so it can't be affected by the professional team, and
it can be seen that it's connected from the source,
the
dna.
However, there is
also a meta blouse field where I spent two days not knowing the beta of Tablo, saying that it has changed again with
this protein up-down.  I know and
miss.
Actually, now I only looked for it while I was presenting this time.
Uh, to the basics, how much the r comics have been relatively researched, so
from 1953 to the recent 2019 that provides about the firm,
this kid comics bp a little bit  I looked at it with the following keywords, but
what is
it? No-
mix is ​​overwhelming.
I want to say that there is something very special about it. I want to talk about it like this. It's a little more foreign than I thought.
So, I want to talk a little bit about the concept of having 5 mixes each
tomorrow.  I'm
trying to talk about Murphy data in line with the times, but I think that the reason why we were
able to produce so much large-capacity data is that technology on the basic side is like
development, but it can be driven.
Big data
can be produced, and the concept of ai is created by the development of rung computers
, so we can obtain high soup data through the foundation to remain in this technology,
and this mayu info mary x that can process it
As we developed together, 5 misses developed really rapidly.
Actually, the next so fun thing is Ohm Access, the equipment used is
slow
.  Number of most used equipment Data from the Beta Science Appraisal in 2020,
ms and ae c come out. Ace is the most dominant with almost 23%,
and then 22%.
Then, if it is related to microarray  Sequencing pcr What's
going on like this
? Basically, the talent is msc data, but it is used very much. 0
Dramatically looking at it, maybe in the future, this proto mix, someone else's tablo mix, the
alto miss, this type of zero 2 Data coming from using sms
5 Biggs about guys  I'm expecting a lot of this to come out,
but I'd like to give a little more friendly explanation for Blackcomb where I am.
Yesterday is the brain
.  You can think of it as sugar coating, and
since we mainly have a lot of that item on the surface of all cells,
I
think this zombie u is appropriate.  Like eating chocolate and
losing money, the temperature of this hand
melts all 2 chocolate dc's and the palm is covered with chocolate.
So, if you look here now, the
mnm friend is like a cup for sugar coating, and the concept of receiving chocolate and being served
. And then, what these people wrote in advertisements
is
Melting your mouse, following Haynes in your mouth, not everyone is high in the hand
.  It's going to hit the jackpot in terms of marketing
.
I gave you a little concept about where on earth you guys are until Cly and gave
me a joy slide.
Practically, we are now doing our hair cells
, but I don't think about using the head. I don't think so.
was seen by an Enbrel stem cell user under a microscope.
Then, here, now, I
attached a florisense tag, and I made a video eyed sean of only the top of Aang Boa
.
At this time, the words that joined the skir made by Aika again
, the distribution is biased a little on the other side, but anyway, the
cell expression is coated inside the working microphone,
so we cola work that  I think you can think of researching ICOM as giving any of these
cells right away and choosing all the cells that can be killed in the system and
adding them to the
second round.  Then, the etymology is very interesting,
the icon is changed into shoes, and then Kelly uses the meaning of a cross coat
.
This is Felix, who knows more about the side with a room like cotton on the top of the exchange.
Then, when we think with common sense, the length of this gla is 2 units. The
conclusion is that the cell surface is located on the outside. It is written by some reaction from the outside.
If it is approaching or there is another cell, or there is a
defeated genie, or there is a hammer, or somehow Lemorique was connected, or Taksim
I Crawl liver, some virus, etc.
, the
component that first interacts with this cell is Klei Khan Tang. So, like this  Recently, the importance of sugar
has become more recognized.
Hey, it's because of when it comes out of the nose.
Yo
So, now our Banga students have made some ideal art
, and we send the cells to Earth like this to compare
.
Everything in this world
except for the party  I did it with the concept of not being able to explain. We also talk about bacteria, 2 weeks
micro balm, but in conclusion, the coolness of bacteria is the same for lol and expo
isaccharide viruses.
After that, 2 minutes
of Quents, besides the mock mother's mocking for the first time since we were born, the malt
thing teases me and creeps me out.
It can be said that everything is made up of 2 squares.
Actually, if you look at 2 Humans, we are like the representative distant money people, and we made a little bit
.
Well, when you catch a cold, the things that come out sticky from your nose are so sticky because they contain sugar
Blood, then breast milk, then the semen of someone else's
baby, after midnight, then fish glass
.  It contains all of them, and basically, this sugar is included
, because that sugar is a kind of mucus, which is a characteristic that appears in our body when there is sugar.
It's coated.
Even if there are tears in the lacrimal points, sticky mucus comes out, and a lot of
phlegm comes out, and the same goes for semen.
If you look at it as a cell surface
membrane, like Auri Grime nm issue is coated, there are
now various policies when he and Icahn are bound
.
You know this, there is also a professional team, and there are also 5 goals of specific evil
There are also cases where only Aika Arms are created, or there are cases
where we have the meaning of Font Girl Aika, such as 1 control t serpent, which is boarding saying that joints are good.
There are 7 prequel icons like League items, and the
only one that
is not a 3 Pore Plasma Membrane is Jade, Aidan, and Rum Graco
Protein.
In spite of this, we now
have the main job in the glycan and give it only mouth work, but there are not many types of blocks
.
So, if you look at the structure of this monosaccharide quality, the fish source crab estimate workflow course
galactose mannus is like this, then you can see the table now, there is hex
resolution, and then d xt is cheap.
In gist of dcs mha Chichi 4, because of this strong,
we do not have a sheet for Ram to weave, so rather 10
humans receive 7 monosaccharides and synthesize many sugars.
I'll make something that's not a microphone. So generally, since it's an angle Leica, the
app t Asparaji is connected, then the app t
4 o'clock Lynn and Threonine's Kaz
.  Do Kyung-Wan, the liver of
the Wenger Family
Depending on what the basic 100 won is,  But it's very easy to buy, so mass
begum all have the same molecular weight
.
Then, ml far away, ahhh, when you go to feed, the pain is
very different. So in the case of the plant, there
are a lot of 2 pieces that do not fit this fur, and this sten appears as a hyper-made show nation
.
As I said before, it's not far off, but after
that, the human in the area where gc is very major is difficult, and he has one less monosaccharide than in the later years,
and in the variety, he and 2nd bullet get
it,
and then instead of the above base  There are many Aikas in the form of uac.
Even if you go to the evolutionary side like this below, there are a lot of very interesting phenomena
.
We are conducting related research. So,
in general, 8 fields have been summarized by Kim Jo-
eul.  Then, to really
clean, we used chocolate and
biomarkers because we thought that if the design reacts sensitively to any environment,
it could be used for diagnosis.
Then, now, the summer brain that we've been focusing on a little bit lately. In fact
, most of the over-frames exist, but they're less than 1% in that child's box except for this one
.
A
little bit of my research saying that Bung Cheon is very deeply involved.  As it comes out little by little, this
importance is being recognized a lot, and because of Apple, the icon is
mapped for the first time. 1
Then, from head to toe, we will do
it later.  'cause I did a cargo
at some time, so the fda profiled the icons a little bit to see what they
were. Then basically, these two things are what I'm giving a lot of action now.
It's not easy to come to the leaf,
so I'm conducting research on McDodds who will be able to make this kind of buyer who can constantly see it.
Also, I'm building a 4ra base Culcom 4ra base so that I can use the data I've created
. Also, recently,  Now, ai 4th people say let's do some voices, so
I asked if I got this and introduced it. As the first word, a point
biopharmaceutical 4. What kind of evaluation
?  I'm
doing research on the ai platform because I'm going to use it for comparative analysis by spreading something similar.
After seeing all the other talk of the doctor Rent today, there are a lot of these two products now, and
maybe that's why I'm invited or invited to announce it
.  There are also various sources, gold, and other
books, and there are also crab irons, so there are various methods of ionization, and
then various resolutions, and then select meetings
, etc.  I'm making some effort to get the cutting
and oh we have that icon  But I don't put all the sauces in
, so I'm very active in international cooperation.
It's difficult, yes, but
when we look at the analysis, it goes into 31%. Well, I said something like this, but
there are three major difficulties in analyzing application knives.
And there are no rules for synthesizing this, so we say it as “You Tempo and E
-Live Thing Kiss.”
Are you looking at repairing agents attached to this sequence linkage Alba form
or beta spring? Then take off two.
There are so many that the number of children consumed under the three fields cannot rise,
then one protein per one rule is good, but that's  No, protein has a
lot of putin sites that can be attached to sugar, and the next one attached to that one site
is not usually attached again, but in very different amounts in Greece.
Documentation is very difficult. I'll explain even if it's a little hot.
When you make an animation and make it like that, how are all the coding codes connected, and those things, you
learn chicken, so you will have some memories. So, it is synthesized so that the die side is possible like this.
The conclusion is almost oops Shinchon spoiler a
That's why Icahn's path is unraveled, so when you hold on to it, the various
icons are involved in the transform race.
At that time, we went mainly to the enzyme half at the conclusion, so we all learned about enzyme reactions,
but even if the ph of the environment is very sensitive, even if the ph is slightly different  Sometimes enzymes don't have 4,
so there will be experiences like this. So,
as I receive enzymes, it affects my physiological sense system so much that it is impossible to
predict for generations.
For example, irresponsible biopharmaceuticals are also biosimilars  I just need to make it the same as
the one I made, but the respiration and performance are what I made, the balmo application came out, and I
threw away what I received. This brother thinks so differently
and adjusts the biological system.
If you go ahead and do this, the cove you want will never happen.
So anyway, the application space like this will be in the process of enzyme release
, so let's not have it.
Same,
150 refrigeration me involved at this time, only 4 7 diabetes, but 1 second
saccharide.
I prepared to give an example of the volume.
If you look at it like this, it is said that we are now a distant source perm per 6 rounds
.  When we meet, we can meet one-two or we can meet one-
3d, and there are so many possibilities. So,
these possibilities are now connected to the Icahn monosaccharide and the monosaccharide.
Leaving
Switzerland Aspara in Jinhae like this on x  Even when things stick together, because let's get to the angle and
where the atmosphere is different, I've been thinking about that possibility all along, and at the end we're
going to make one of these Tektro Cy, Tide, and Icahn.
I don't know if it's produced, but anyway,
it's really difficult because it's made with Lee Jung-dae's interest.
Also, I mentioned it a little bit at the beginning,
but if you see it with a plot, you can actually do it.
There
are several sites with li columns attached. If
you look somewhere, there are a lot of Anger Galgal
.  t use different macro lenses and
then in one site, the amount is different,
so it is not only suitable to study it in a cow suffering from micro sd ent like
this.  It's
a spike clutch Now, people first saw it well, hyung, I looked at it well,
analyzed the structure of the neck, and ah,
it's going to
be all right now.  Because we tried to perfect the structure analysis,
the first squad of the Star 2 Pro Team
was very danced like this, so everything was blocked like
this.
Looking at the site of Spike Floating,
there are a little over 120 sites that can hold
the iCOS art.
I didn't read it and the fee was also 5. That's right. If you
go to 20 of these, you can't usually upgrade
.
Maybe they all have bindings,
so I don't know where to go from before the guests to the area for those things, but I'd like to talk about something that's a little bit like Spike Project,
Sean Lei Shen, and it's hugely complicated.
This is the data created by
jpo So oh oh oh oh, it's one of the very Carta biopharmaceuticals, and it's
also a treatment for heart failure. It's a cytokine-type drug.
Half-life and then
ah, stability and heap. It's that ALCAD that all of these things are related to. It
's good to analyze this accurately.
In this way, the same cli course is called Ation, but it is not the same
ambivalence, but another picture from a site-specific and overall macroscopic point of view.
There was a lot of effort to analyze that child curry, and
it is still being done. In the
early days, there was even one side of my king that came up, because
I can quickly recognize such a terminal structure in the grid column. So at once
After screening such a large amount, we can see it, but overall structural
information cannot be obtained, but still,
there is a leptin torpedo method that is used very much in Stingak to the extent
that it is still very much like this.  There is an lcb that has been used a lot for a very long time
.  There are too many things that people do not have,
and when people do basic research, this is why, because
they know more than 150 things and are involved in practice habits,
they create an island that is involved in this way, so the lack of a standard for this becomes a very slight disadvantage, so
actually  The Aita list is moving a lot to the mas base
.
So, I recommend something very interesting. Most of the research in this section is on the web
It's a bit more cowardly than a trap, Corel
Trace Firm in Psy Colt is such a used equipment, but in fact, I also worked on it as a
major recollection, and
you can think of it as the best equipment to be braided. Next, you can think of qc as a good equipment.
It's an excellent equipment. Since
there is no stand for why, when we got the correct medicine value, there were things that
we could do with the unknown ring target that we picked up like this
.
So, if you have a lot of dft mistresses like this,
the gla 2 compartment itself is not as big as 5% chin,
and the car doesn't open much
.  You can go by selling it with some advantages
Just then, because another point comes next, you can get any structural information,
but now, uh,
what is a dishonored Benz?
After filming this once, ah, continue  There are a lot of pensions, there are a lot of
children, and there are flyers, so there are really a lot of things, but in SSec,
the core of all Icahn's analysis problems is going to the number.
It's
becoming a lot
because Mai 23 Foray can be done in
lc, and I took all the advantages of swarms again.
It's
always the case, but now Jiang Zemin has one point as a downside, and now the price is getting more and more expensive.
I don't divide the month
, and Icahn garlic is selectively jumped out of the system, removed, and concentrated.
At this time, I feel the number of reservations, but I can't send
them all.  If you do ms, why is it
purple instead of
the number of li colors?
Also
, the Intestine signal that is coming out now is taken a lot from the bottom of the answer post, and you
can get some information about the Urban Dawn season
.
Then, I know again. Now, the pre-mentation patterns are different again.
Director can get information about structured.
This is actually a sub-liquid body.
It is known that this kolygo saccharide is and covers  It's said that retention
is good, but why did I write it because there was little scientific basis for it?
So now, more than 1,100 structures are looking for this gift, so in
fact,
now people are doing more research on liquid simulation or something like that.
Yes, there is also a lot of research related to micro-bio stowage, and whether or not this is lost,
uh this way, we made a study of writing i cup, so that a very purple
string can be separated from something, and
then we do a very small amount.  Being able to analyze is a very big merit. So
, in order to reduce all of this a little more, the variety of any method of analysis in Clay Khan, and then the quality of analysis in some way,
uh this 1 3 4  Let me explain a little about the Alf John Lei Shen internet study of the antibody that I did in the list that started the scheme
ha ah ah I'll explain
a little bit
.
The control is now participating in the money system of Chungnam National University
, so in A List, they give a standardization work to
a mA block called A 1 List Antibody, and we now suffer there
, analyze and interpret Sean Lei Shen in our own way, and report the report.
So, if you look at it, there is something wrong, and then stop now,
even mothers are discriminated against by cheap machines
.
Looking at the next period, I'm sure that the US and the movement have been geared up a little more on the European side in the plan.
Guyo saddle also contributes about 4%. And
basically, many people in the Indus have issued a report, and then it should be after that
. Now, the government is divided in this way
.
It's not me in 2020, but one of the interesting things is
that even if you do a tombstone like this flytan, there are various ways like this, and there are various delights like this, and
because of that, the analysis with typeface is also good, and the perspective is also good
.
Icahn can be said to be the simplest, and easily anyone can do it easily among those who listen to this lecture.
There must be a lot of people who have it, but
nevertheless, the diversity of methods is used in various ways for the target, and then
, if you look at the way to look at the ali server, 1 day now, anger is the key.
In this way, outliers
can see much more condolences, and in
the case of Cai So-so, Gary Edition Time can be omitted, but
there are various ways to make this kind of show through a cheap tandem that is not worth doing in your head.
It's the item with the antibody, but
if you say you're still looking at the li column, you jump down the gla 2 column itself and the key
red indicates gla, but there are many cases where you see the clai board
.  There are times when I see it, and there are times when I send it as an in-tag like this. So
even if I see 2 columns, I see something like that in various forms.
Another one is now an analysis method.
They say they are going by sms,
but this is probably  Isn't this like that? Looking at 100 reports, one of the interesting things is
that lc is perfect. Yes, it is actually possible based on ncf fd. If
setter was number 26, msm sc-fdma s
So now, it shows that a lot of model studies are being done based on lcms.
Now, the color hair is like this.
A lot of analysis has been done, and the
same service period has been given to other Asian countries. Now
, there are also Trat jane's multi-vendors, and there are also Caspian
thefts over the cost of bunt.  Universities have the most diversity,
but the results are in this case.
What I wanted to show in this study was
a solution and some tools for comparison between an analyte and then an experiment containing mainly properties of its structure, which is of many styles.
It explains, but what's really interesting is that it's
just that, and
some values ​​in the consensus that can be accepted by anyone
don't depend on a specific method or type of laboratory.
The way Lei Shen of the 2nd course sees
it can be very diverse.
But now, the level of difficulty is very different, and then the way of approaching something is very
different.
It seems that there was some motivation for such a research that explained the next part in a constricted way, saying,
This is not what I am talking about now.
How much is
it?  I made a roadmap for the future Royal Road *
, and one of the reports that came out at that time was a report called krs forming, know science.
I'm receiving it, and I'm starting it. I'm talking about what I want to say.
But the biggest reason among them is that I'm talking about this kind of analytical tone
, so later, as a conclusion, I dare to say
this.  I'm talking about this by m-atx tool
work, but it's very necessary, but maybe this is what I
want to say, so it reflects it as it is.
I came out to see it, so I found it, and in a recent thesis,
the title of Bonnie Sayra Benson, a 2 pro team vine, was good, and the title made me cry,
but
I will believe in Forte.
It's a base,
so there are a lot of things made like this based on a variety of harsh five-
pointed notation or something
based on Squalls.
There are overwhelmingly many dishes,
but if you look at the numbers, then it's still obviously more analytically difficult,
sleeping a child is more difficult, and even though there's no standard
, if you
're in this cliché comics base answer, you're still doing it.
Go in and stand, there is [ __ ], and there is a bit of a dog buff rim
, but something beneficial, and it could be the 2 major labels based in Europe
.
that  There are alcohol
mixes or bases,
but now, if you look at it, uh, I pulled it out among the representative terra basses, and
now I know it and recognize
it as a sto.
It's a lot of time rather than picking. Since there is no base
, based on the existing references,
I combined the Icahn mass of the things they found and the Icahn mass of the things they found, and then I
made it based on some total writing key. So this is  When I want to get information
that is not something in a specific system but something like this Icahn I frequent
, if this
is rescued , it is basic for the road to tell me that this is going to be like this by launching from somewhere else
.  There are always deficiencies to see the reality I have in , but I am in
this tower,
so when I am going to talk about creating a database, but I can see it by
default.
One of the things that are used a lot now is
to use The Glucose Unit for that course.
When the lock is connected, with the u hitting time, and
then with the correct value, I draw a calibration curve
.
This is a language program that does not have such a fight in the corresponding live. So, there
are many things using Lee Ji-yu in the Aegi Naji Motors in Naju-dong, Ajou-dong, and there are
advantages of fate.  When people
don't know the structure of o'clock or how to do it, they analyze it, how can Loco,
then gu once, draw the calibrator cover, and get dark data
once with idg ?  It's dark in Icahn, but it works
better. This is rather than Icahn, what we have to get by looking at the bot directly in
.
Because it's not Ian Uh Eol in the difference, for example,
even though it's a very common Dola 2 in Hang Chu, I'm caught and used again as a major, and
I'm getting rid of it in a little inconsistent way that I'm not good at it with fire.
If you overcome it a bit, anyone can use it easily. He said let's
make the first episode base first, so we are
making the Icahn Zera base based on a cms.
You can get the corresponding po call composition. After that, you can get all the
spectra for each team through this tation tine and
msm, which you can get from lc, into the ike icom db.
If
you say no, you can't itemize everything. Now we have to categorize a little bit. So, as we have research
fields, those who are analyzing whether to find the most in Korea right now, what are
the cases that non-experts must do?  It is
a biopharmaceutical for much, so even in biopharmaceuticals, first of all
, the antibody data rs I refer to these antibodies by
commercially purchasing them and making the Icahn db like
this.  When I did the analysis, this
hms  So that we can get information about these things with the Dera base article,
the child's id will be the most basic,
and then strict is what I want to analyze with what I want to do with what
references the stain quality of oss dust.  I think it's also possible. It's possible to insulate cool Eta comparisons through the hole. Well,
it's said that you can monitor the r column that expresses immunity to this specific evil,
but all of these parts can be done.
So when we create the database around  It's
like using the Berkeley course unit that I showed you earlier. As
for how we did it, uh, first of all, I'm basically a person who plays Max, so I really
like to buy Willis immediately that day, but
here we are trying to make a Dera base  So, it
's very good to remove unnecessary information as much as possible. For example, as an excuse earlier, I
wrapped the second round with him in sf, and I got children to let others know
.  To get rid of it
, I attach some ab labeling tags rather than handmade ones. Then, yo yo,
if you attach a raven tag, you can now get it very simply with one signal without any alphabet
numbers.
It is not possible to produce ms and ml 3 earlier, and since all these data are 1 spectral
, an impsul is put in the form of a base.
So, if you experiment using this created
db, the db values ​​in the db until the experiment  As a parent, it is compared like already, and the
closest thing we have in the db is which one of your experimental values ​​is the closest,
so that Icahn is able to id, so
we are a developer who has been locked in excellent since the second half of 2019.
Now you might be wondering, but why are you suddenly trying to label ab
?  But when I showed you the list data a while ago, when I said
how people are making data all over the world, there are
a lot of cases where all of them are Kleikan language writers when analyzing with this antibody basin 4-ply kosher race.
Next time, I'm using a lot of Philip's in the cell line like
this. Then, if I look at the language, I use it the most with any deal beta 2g.
If we create this type of database that separates with 2 clicks and inputs 2 to 2 bling, many people
think that it will be really useful 2 me, so we are approaching this way.
When I had a rave in my mouth and
now analyzed and disputed with lc, this is now
the human lig who wrote the standard before.  Hugh Verizon will already
tell you that he is already a client, but he buys him often, so he's going to be a star,
and then he doubles them first with the Ironization time base, and
he's going to be a kid again
.  Even though we heard it, it falls under number 1
, and we will find out that it is a child like these guys through things like oh my
tandem rte exo glucose ace and that
's how a db is completed.
When Japan analyzes under the given conditions, it can be seen that rtd Oro has it
. Then, when we point out this biopharmaceutical, although it is a language sample
, the dog is obviously different
Being able to predict that it will have this shape without analysis
is also very important to our method.  It's a little nice and a little ah, what's the very good part? A
child joiner Sephora Room 2 works very well
Underneath, uh, practically 2 Yoran isola Ah, if you look at the reins, the conclusion is that it's cancerous
.
If you look closely at this, the points at the end of the value except for the fact come out very similar,
but it is separated because of this difference in retention time
.  The intensity is slightly different for each
ratio length. So, when we put this kind of information,
we can get exactly what shape the
muffin is.
Yes, even if I have to do a figure skating a bit through dealing, there seems
to be no difference
in pitching.  Because the internet stay time is different and
the efficiency of these children's tenders is different, ultimately it will be solved or it will
come out as much as possible
.
So we don't think so, then there is practically no test of popularity.
Then, when we run the Taylor base, if we find the best match,
it comes out as a score like this.
The data in the form of a monthly clock is given as an opinion.
So, he, who we are touching, once the dera base is
complete as an
orderer, covers a variety of antibody medicines.
Get Rid Of Humira Maybe A Steam
Adventure  In time, it's just Remicade, but there are still 5 plans with
that li column registered, and there are about 70 about him. In other
words, 7 help easily
.  About 8 of these
Icahns are eating away. So, currently, 200 ms ms
data are input
.  If you take a picture, take it and upload the datum
. So, we are making some names that you can check in
real time
.  Then, each of the
3400 sugar flowers in the library will give you a code like this for tree exo spox.
Go to Spectra, then again, how much is the pre-cursor ion, and even the energy settings are all set.
What kind of ion was obtained from the gripping tip?
We
make them one by one and get them in such a way that we input them like
this. So, if we look at this market ordinance database, we
did it with the ps map, which is the absolute Ysera fring map of the Blyth ride section lighthouse.
Then, these scores come out, and then, first of all, the
score comes out again from the database itself.
So, when I was playing, now each of them is obtained together with the otn formation.
Child So based on this, when the ID is finished
, now the arcana 2d result Spectra Now the computer null Regent
result Then, what is the result of this msi computer Then
what is it? With the first three, we can do qualitative analysis  At that time
, with the data of the last No. 2, we say that it is now possible for quantitative analysis.
So, for example, if we say that we randomly
found a compound in 4.29 3
I speak sugar code, and the library budget showed a willingness of 9:1 4%, and the dba showed 96.4%.  To be more precise,
I want to show that sin can do some schooling.
4-year-old Practically, we are now filling up all
these gossips one by one.
For qualitative analysis, I am filling in the relevant information now.
So, recently, if I do something a little differently,
I am now doing what I need. Why did I get a lot of questions in the past?
In fact, I received a lot of questions saying, “Do 2 spaces”,
but I did not know how
to do it backwards. I was asked why I should label it when I buy it.
I didn't even use nc, which requires Clover Four,
but
these days, in fact, when you analyze biopharmaceuticals like this, you
have to pay for lc data and ms data at the same time, so
you label for l and just send it for ms  not like this
Let's do the bling all at once and miss the El Cid direct ball.
So I'm trying to find a lot of my bling in the color of chom So water 3 or something wrapping oh oh it's expensive,
but they
say it goes well in January.
These labelings made with uh
are used a lot together so that we can increase the test we did. So uh, we also
go to the daily dish and put a little big step on it, even though it's not a level horn, and they give
me a tag to take me number 2 well.  It makes Yona's Lee happen more efficiently from before
.
I used it to make my own bling. So, when you do a PC with a confined
honorific,
ah
ah, now it's all ticked, so we'll do as you're told, and we
'll do the analysis like this and report it then really practically
basically  I don't know av labeling. When using this tinting, the intensity is definitely good.
So, we were able to improve the signal by up to 12 fisheries
. So, the efficiency of the Lorotene points when making the answer is yes.
Den Then
, there is such an advantage that you can create the next adira base. Yes,
right now, we are processing and analyzing the number of samples with the inside of the data in this way
.  In this form, where you can make a base and upload it
, how to buy it in the anime game school program line story,
people are making some people who can use
it very easily.
I told you a little bit about what comics are, and then I told you a little bit
about how much Cry Comics has developed, and
then Juke r Comics isn't easy
.  There are hurdles, but with this go icom
2 quad, now I work hard and work hard on the periphery like this,
so obviously now,
I'm thinking about trying to guess a world where anyone can easily analyze the icom 2 quad and do it.
All the results that come  It's not that all of them stopped, it's the result of our group members' efforts
.
Especially regarding labeling, one day here is Seo Jung-ah's student, and
then Awoori's middle school student Asana Riddick, a doctor of cryptography, did a lot of hard work.
Next time, I will finish the presentation with this.
This is the email. Then, our homepage, at least recently, we
also opened a YouTube
channel.
Thank you
4 Thank you for the valuable lecture of Jesus
Yesterday I was listening intently, but currently there are still more studies on
Genomix, but I hope that it will be done through the professor so that there is nothing more to say about the iCraft play.
It's a part of Danjeong that we
're working hard on building the client database that we're currently collaborating with.
It seems to have been the content.
Yes, then we will proceed with the qna time.
Now, approach the manny gq na window below and post questions about this part of the crane that you are curious
about.
to give time  I will
also inform you that the session will be available to watch again even after today's reason today. If
you
watched yesterday and have any questions, please write a little in the qna below
, so that we can respond and collect answers now.
Yes, then, thank you for giving us your valuable time today.
Ah again, I hope you will attend various parts such as the Paige Exhibition Hall
and get a lot of information.
Then, thank you for taking the time to support us today.